thank you very much thank you
dan
thank you huddersfield
what a pleasure to be here
and what am i said both barrels of the
linguistic department introducing me i'm
very touched very honoured thank you
um now
um
golly lecture what right well
first of all i should bid you good
evening of course um to academic
students and
linguists lovers of language i obviously
thank you for coming but
um thank you to um
not just the interested parties as it
were but most especially to those from
outside the field of language
though actually that of course is an
impossibility if you can hear and
understand this then you are as much
inside the field of language as anyone
else as the most distinct grow up will
you
i couldn't resist it i'm very sorry um
but what i mean is to extend a very
special warm welcome to those of you who
are simply language curious if you like
so
well it's a strange thing to be giving a
talk about language in languages alan
watts once said about something it's
it's a bit like trying to bite your own
teeth
uh but i nonetheless thank you
huddersfield university and babel
magazine for giving me the chance to try
and fail
scarcely a day goes past
in the press the general press without
an article breaking news of a discovery
pertinent to the origins of language or
fresh developments in neuroscience or
news stories of
the death of languages or lamentations
on the subject of the apparently chronic
and dismal degradation of proper usage
the latest brain science
and its insights on language are of
course fascinating but i'm equipped
neither to understand them properly nor
communicate them in anything other than
the most amateur and bumbling way nor
can i claim anything remotely
approaching true expertise in
linguistics or any other related
academic field despite plenty of jolly
layman's curiosity about the history and
development of neuro linguistics
philology phonetics
lexicography and all the branches of
language study that you can happen upon
or throw a grant at for all that
enthusiasm
it would be fruitling of me to attempt
to discourse
on
for example
new thinking on the sapir wharf
hypothesis or my pet subject in the
original title for this lecture that i
first offered synchronic anomalies in
the erosion of uralic post alveolar
fricatives
i'm joking of course it's obvious that i
would have concentrated on diachronic
not synchronic erosion but nor am i a
polyglot although i have a damn good go
wherever i find myself i have reasonable
french and german acceptable studenty
spanish general tourist greek art
gallery italian and i think possible
brothel dutch
so
yeah it is a l netherlands so um the
question remains how can i presume to
lecture on language from so unqualified
a position merely because i write read
talk tweet blather burble praten prattle
a lot well i walk a lot but i wouldn't
be expected to lecture on lower limb
anatomy and the ambulatory sciences and
i eat a lot but i'm hardly qualified
either to discourse on matters culinary
and gustatory
language of course does not belong
uniquely to linguists or to writers
broadcasters and those of us who use
language professionally after all you'd
be hard put to find anyone who doesn't
use language professionally for
all of us from cabinet ministers to
cabinet makers from hedge trimmers to
hedge funders from barristers to
baristas language is more essential than
legs so what singles me out what
entitles me why the hell am i standing
here
you're right goodbye no
no no no um i take it that i'm here
because it might be apparent from much
of what i've said and written over the
years that i have a perhaps more than
usually great love of language and a
more than usually high doctrine of its
defining role in our human natures a
playful love sometimes a mocking love
but always a deep one and that is my
subject tonight not so much what we have
here is a failure to communicate a line
i'm sure you all remember strother
martin delivering in the great film
cohen luke
i gave that in haste i'll be honest when
i was asked for a title it seemed likely
to cover just about anything
but i think the actual title which i
hope you'll agree by the end is more
accurate and simpler in a way language
what we have here is a failure to love
it enough
now if it doesn't seem too
self-indulgent and frankly even if it
does the best way to demonstrate this at
the outset my love of language might be
to show you a sketch from a very early
episode of a show called a bit of frying
laureate a tv show that i wrote and
performed with my colleague and friend
hugh laurie many many many years ago
when all around here was green fields
the
sketch is called let's talk about
language linguists amongst you will
notice some of the influences and
references but anyway it this perhaps
can serve as my job application for the
post of 2022 babel lecturer so if we can
douse the lights thank you very much and
roll vt
well yes very silly and of course it is
absolutely typical of my life with hugh
that i had to learn all those lines and
he just has to
widen those beautiful blue goggly eyes
and steal all the laughter but it knows
it was such fun doing that but where did
this special love of what did i call it
in the sketch my brother my sister my
mother my friend my nurse made this
thing in this language why
where did it come from why did i have
this special relationship
i like to say that i fell in love with
language from an early age simply
because i had nowhere else to go
from close to the beginning of
consciousness i could tell that compared
to other children i was hopeless but
anything physical or athletic i've never
for example been able even when young
and bendy to be able to sit cross-legged
tailor-fashioned as they used to call it
let alone climb a rope or dive into
water or throw myself into the ground in
order to stop a cricket ball or even to
catch a cricket ball i couldn't and i
can't and i'll never be able to nor was
music any better i couldn't count or
come in on time couldn't sing even
remotely in tune or clap on the beat or
off the beat whatever that means and as
for dancing to this very day the word
dance makes me shiver and writhe and
come close to vomiting with horror and
unhappiness
nor could i draw mold sculpt craft saw
stitch model or paint without making a
horrific mess
and so for the first few years of life i
thought of myself as entirely useless
more or less a waste of skin
you can cry ah if you like
so
i did enjoy stories though i'd sit in
bed with a torch
in my boarding school when i was young
and tell tales to the dormitory after
lights out and from the first that dread
english sneer too fond of the sound of
his own voice followed me everywhere
i was at the sort of school that
started teaching you french and latin
when you were about eight or nine so
i did take those and i enjoyed them
enough for the latin master to suggest i
might enjoy adding ancient greek to my
studies which i did the different
alphabet thrilled me instantly why
didn't english have a phi or a psi or
a theta i wondered i started to spell
stephen with the internal phi and i
taught the alphabet to friends so we
could use it as a secret code and the
etymological side of things appealed as
well the greek book that i was given to
work from like to teach new vocabulary
by
way of derived english cognates so
graphene to write can be remembered the
book would say by thinking about
graphics and telegraphs
gramane and phonos put us in mind of
gramophone that sort of thing i'll never
forget coming across the noun thauma in
that book which was accompanied by this
note this is easily remembered by
thinking of the english word thaumaturge
which brought me up a bit short it's not
a word that 10 year olds often use and
the book was right however because i i
had to go and look it up and i've never
forgotten it since as i'm sure you know
and don't need reminding fauma means
miracle in greek or wonder
and thus a thaumaturge is a miracle
worker but i liked english yes but to me
at first that was just a subject like
maths or geography or history and i
liked learning other tongues but i never
thought
much about language itself choir
language
i did recall an early music lesson the
teacher wrote up on the blackboard
orchestra and i squeaked out instantly
cart horse
because the anagram had leapt out at me
and everyone stared at me as if i was a
freak and that's how i felt about it it
didn't feel like a skill that i could be
proud of though many years later the
reward for this pointless ludic facility
um
was when i was having dinner with the
great alec guinness the the actor
obi-wan kenobi if you don't know him
from anything else
and i was able to tell him that his name
is an anagram of genuine class
which pleased him very much indeed
so while i was slow with numbers and
slow with science and worse than slow
with anything involving physical
movement speed or grace i was quite
agile with words with puns and
spoonerisms and anagrams just the kind
of skills that illicit groans and shrugs
from decent people everywhere
puberty however brought a new
relationship and a deeper relationship
i've told this story before but
it strikes at the very heart of my
relationship with language and i thought
it worth going into here
i was raised in god's other
own county norfolk
home
was a 12 mile bike ride away from the
throbbing
metropolitan gomorrah that was norwich
my life literally resembled therefore
that of the great clergyman sydney smith
who when translated to a remote rural
rectory wrote to his friend lady holland
my living in yorkshire is so far away
that i am actually 12 miles from the
nearest lemon
and
i grew up 12 miles from a library a
cinema or coffee bar let alone a lemon
and twelve hundred miles from lemon
grass
anyway
one rainy afternoon i was about maybe 12
years old i turned on the television and
the film had just started five minutes
in so i didn't catch the title the
moment i started to watch i found myself
becoming more and more transfixed
it was the language that engrossed me
the film was set in the past i knew it
wasn't as old as shakespeare or even
jane austen but i couldn't quite place
the period it was very elegant very
charming but the language
i had never heard anything like it it
made me almost want to dance me dance
but there was something so joyfully
perfect about it it was funny too
incredibly funny
a new kind of funny however so elegance
has swiftly yet effortlessly delivered
the rhythm and the patterning were
divine a whole new kind of music
at some point a young man knelt in front
of a young woman and said
i hope i shall not offend you if i state
quite frankly and openly that you seem
to me to be in every way the visible
personification of absolute perfection
and it was as if i'd been punched in the
solar plexus
lines of this dizzying splendor unrolled
throughout i wanted to jump through the
screen and join the easy but thrilling
eloquence and the sweet grace of their
articulation a funniness the proper word
for which i now know to be wit
soon it was it was over i ran to my
mother mummy mummy i cried
i hope i shall not offend you if i say
that you seem to me to be in every way
the visible personification of absolute
perfection darling what are you talking
about and i explained what i'd seen and
heard and described the setting and the
characters oh said my mother that that
that would have been oscar wilde's the
importance of being earnest
and i wanted to know more she thought
there might be a copy of the play in the
house somewhere but i couldn't find it
but never mind despite being 12 miles
from the nearest lemon or perhaps
because of it the great county of
norfolk in those days sent out mobile
libraries into the remotest countryside
ours came every other thursday to a
meeting of lanes not far from the house
so the next appointed day the great gray
van rumbled into my fevered view the
driver stopped climbed down into the
road
wheezed round to the side opened a door
there let down some steps and patted my
bottom up and into the library that was
acceptable behavior in those days the
librarian welcomed me aboard and she sat
behind the counter a sweet old thing in
a lemon-colored cardigan she had soft
powdery cheeks and spectacles on a chain
that rested on an ample bosom think of a
sort of fluffy margaret rutherford
such people don't exist anymore really
do they they belong to a world when
babies went in prams not strollers and
men had brill creamed hair and yellow
nicotine stained fingers and women went
shopping in hair curlers
oh get on with it stephen so
she said what can we do for you young
man and i said well i hope i shall not
offend you if i stayed quite openly and
frankly
you seem to me to be in every way this
visible personification of absolute
perfection i beg your pardon and then i
told her might i have a copy of the
importance of being earnest by oscar
wilde and she pointed and there sure
enough low on the shelf oscar wilde the
four comedies a woman of no importance
an ideal husband lady fandemier's wind
and heaven be praised the importance of
being earnest she stamped the book out
with that springy thump which is heard
no more in the world and i ran panting
home clutching the book to my heaving
breast for two weeks i read the play
every day twice a day three times a day
and the others which i liked
but not so much it was the importance to
which i attached so much
well importance
what was it about that phrase that first
triggered me
it's worth trying to drill a little
deeper
i hope i shall not offend you if i state
quite frankly and openly that you seem
to me to be in every way
the visible personification of absolute
perfection it's elegant and beautifully
balanced it's uh
above all though funny but why is it
funny and at the risk of breaking a
butterfly on a wheel or taking a spade
to a souffle i think now that the line's
effect
springs from philological roots that the
listener instinctively understands
without needing to know anything about
etymology and diachronic linguistics and
english's mongrel mix of romance and
germanic tongues
somehow we just know
without being told that declarations of
love
should be made using anglo-saxon words
because anglo-saxon is honest it's
truthful it can be trusted we expect
you're so great you're the tops you be
my bride you stun me you knock me for
six you're my dreamboat may i kiss you i
want you for my own i love you
but wilde gives algernon
the character who speaks the line first
yes a solid train of short anglo-saxon
words you seem to me to be in every way
but suddenly that train draws into a
very latinate station
the visible personification of absolute
perfection if algernon meant
what he was saying if he was caught up
in sincere feelings of love surely he
wouldn't take time to express it like
that
and yet the very fact of being able to
come up with so intricate a phrase is in
itself a loving compliment too so it's a
contradiction like dr doolittle's push
me pull you it's both from the heart and
the head
i might say laughter fills the space
between these contradictions or that
laughter is
plucking on the overstretched strings of
cognitive dissonance i might say that
but then you would think me a
pretentious twasic so i can't but in a
strange way the whole business of what's
anglo-saxon and what's latin it strikes
at the heart of so much english history
english the language and english the
people
on the one hand we have
robin hood falstaff toby belch fair
saxon yeoman bowman blue-eyed utterers
of good saxon oaths flackson-head
scoffers down of good saxon cakes and
ale and on the other
the norman sheriff of nottingham guy of
gisborne malvolio with their lank black
greasy severus snape hair and their long
fancy greasy words
the story we tell ourselves or perhaps
more truthfully the story we used to
tell ourselves right up through my
childhood feeds into this myth and it is
entirely a myth
the merry england story of solid hearts
of oak saxon honesty and directness
resisting those puritanical bureaucratic
and corrupt machiavellian frenchies
kind hearts and simple faith trumping
coronets and norman blood
the honest you would longbow versus the
cruel iron crossbow the maple versus the
chain mail
you might even find a distorted deluded
descendant of this fantasy in the dreams
of the blue-eyed british brexiteer
waving his true blue passport in the
pallid faces of those sneaky euro
villains
having waited an extra two hours in the
non-euq for the privilege of doing so of
course
but norman's
of course were called normans we should
recall because normandy was named after
settlers from the north norse vikings
they were far more likely to be blonde
and blue-eyed frankly than the jute's
celts angles and saxons whose lands they
conquered in 1066 but that myth remains
a deep part of the vision we have of
ourselves fancy words intricate latinate
constructions such folder rolls and
curlicues are deprecated by plain
speaking robin hood ivanhoe percy
blakeney hannah biggles and bond
and there's winston churchill too we
shall fight them on the beaches
hitler can do his worst we shall do our
best
his famous speeches are mostly
compounded of punchy solid monosyllabic
anglo-saxon and then
for perfect glorious effect the odd
latinate phrase decorates the words like
a a heraldic scroll as when on ve day he
preceded his triumphant barks of long
live the calls of freedom
god saved the king
with the exquisite rumble of advance
britannia
but churchill's famous sores and sayings
are for the most part as anglo-saxon as
a bulldog so yes there's a long
tradition of distrusting latin don't use
a five dollar word when a 50 cent word
will do mark twain advised disraeli said
of gladstone a sophistical rhetorician
inebriated with the exuberance of his
own verbosity which has a touch of
exactly that consciously ironic wildey
and self-contradiction using sophistical
rhetoric to condemn sophistical rhetoric
i've taken a long time over that story
of that phrase from the importance of
being earnest and how it lit up so much
excitement in me because i'm aware that
i'm extremely lucky to have had such an
epiphany
the experience with wild took me on
further scrabbling excursions to
libraries to find out more visits that
led of course to the shock of
discovering oscar's terrible fate and
realizing its connection with my own
nature but that's another story for
another day
this is about what wild that self-styled
lord of language did for me until
meeting him i had not understood what
language could do sue i generous in and
of itself
the so-called grandfather of linguistics
noam chomsky the very mention of whose
name elicits cheers and groans in equal
measure did say one thing that i don't
think anyone can dispute whatever the
views on his generative grammar and
embedding and all that he said
it's important to learn to be surprised
by simple facts
most of the world has not learned or
been taught to be surprised by the
simple fact that we all speak and
understand at least one language that
the means of communication that is the
gift of us all
is of so many orders of magnitude more
remarkable than the communication
systems of any other living organisms on
earth
such claims are always hedged with
concessions to whales chimps dogs
bonobos corvids and these days even
trees and their mycelial communication
networks and peppered with phrases like
that we know of so far but as bernard as
bertrand russell observed while a dog
may be able to communicate to you that
it's hungry or wants a walk it can't
tell you that its parents were poor but
honest
there'll always be someone chiming in
with ah but how do you know that the dog
isn't trying to tell you exactly that
only you can't understand it well to
quote russell again that's like saying
we can't know that there isn't a teapot
orbiting the planet venus in such a way
that it's always facing away from earth
and thus remains invisible to us
some claims are so wildly unlikely that
while they may be happily figured in our
dreams and fantasies it seems
nonetheless rather wasteful to figure
them in our thinking and understanding
still these days arguing for linguistic
exceptionalism in the human species can
come over as anthropocentric vanity when
as we know all that we are fit to
express about ourselves is shame
embarrassment and self-disgust we've
moved from guilt at the original sin
that resulted in our expulsion from the
garden of eden to guilt at modern sins
that exclude us from the garden of
nature but that too is a subject for
another day i'm going to take it as read
that the development of language in our
species fifty thousand years ago masso
menos gave us a gift a toolbox a
superpower that is unique to us homo
sapiens or if you're american homo
sapiens
music we know can enrapture our souls
and speak to our deeps it is often
described as beyond language and i think
we can all sense why
music can reach us in ways that words
rarely manage but that doesn't mean that
language can't light music beguile
thrill surprise solace
seduce enchant and enrapture too not
only in what it says but in how it
sounds in how the tip of the tongue taps
and teases the teeth in how the pitch
and timbre swing sweep and swoop in how
the phrases stop and start pause and
proceed syncopate stutter slacken
accelerate rise and fall and as looked
at earlier in how games can be played
with word choice and word history that
tease tickle and touch too
a string of words
can be as rich an offering as a string
of pearls a gift to lay at the feet or
the ears of your interlocutor that can
make them smile clap their hands and
flush with pleasure or to enrage
distress humiliate disappoint and
terrify of course
when we look at a picture in a gallery
we know that sometimes it isn't the
subject depicted that we respond to but
how the paint is laid on the squeeze and
scrape the texture and lickability of it
all the colors and the composition the
painterliness as it's called
so it can be with the worldliness of a
sentence not that it comes when it comes
to utterance there is such a thing as a
sentence of course
roland bart famously identified the
plesial du text and la jouissons to text
the juiciness no one doubts that there
can be enormous or orgasmic as in the
french sense of jewish science but a
deep pleasure and a juicy bliss in
utterance a response that supplants
supersedes and eclipses the meaning that
is there to be conveyed that becomes the
meaning in fact for sometimes it is
exactly and solely the feel and flow of
words that is to be conveyed
not their semantic burden as it says
when an email hasn't been fully
downloaded to your inbox this message
has no content
and hurrah for that the medium is the
message yes but it is also manifestly
true and this is something that the
british in particular i think seem to
find hard to swallow
style can be
substance
so it was anyway that algernon's
seduction of sicily gave me a feeling
that words were a medium like musical
notes or paint dance
pottery coils and every other damn thing
that i was so useless at and it offered
me the dim hope that just as friends who
could play the piano or cricket went to
practice rooms or the nets to improve
and hone their skills then maybe this
could be done with language where others
listen to pink floyd slade or the stones
i listened endlessly to gramophone
records of music hall and radio
comedians to w.h ordon and t.s eliot
reading their poetry and to the speeches
of churchill there really wasn't much
else in the way of spoken word recording
in those days then monty python arrived
oh the joy of that sketch about woody
words and tinny words they got it
my whole waking life began to be more
and more dedicated to being silly and
adventurous with words devising codes
and languages within languages drawing
inspiration from a weird range of
reading that stretched from my three w's
oscar wilde evil in war and pg woodhouse
these i love but also baroness horses
scarlet pimpernell dickens buckin conan
doyle billy bunter mad mix
my friends were discovering new chords
keys and rhythms to play on the guitar
or new strokes of the bat i was
discovering new chord keys and rhythms
to play on the larynx and new strokes of
the pen
not really to any end or because i
thought it was even vaguely important
but simply because it was all that i
could do and i enjoyed it the language
game was for me the only game in town
everyone else played it without seeming
to recognize that it was even a game
for youth rates music and sport well
above the spoken or written word
the others had quickly and instinctively
learned to distrust clever clever
talking and heightened language and my
daft ways of speaking didn't endear me
either to my school fellows or school
teachers
such silliness and verbal trickery was
not after all something you could turn
into a career was it
actually
talking of careers the school actually
had a careers officer uh who we had to
visit for advice and so on he asked me
if i had any future career in mind and i
remember telling him i said i want a job
where you don't have to be qualified or
know anything at all
and you get paid for sitting around
being useless and never have to lift a
finger
i want to be a school's career officer
so that's the kind of awful person i was
i'm afraid anyway music painting and so
on are gifts and accomplishments whose
rarity bestows high value poor old
language is common currency
karl kraus
put it rather eye wateringly but will
allow for his age and customs my
language he said is the universal [ __ ]
that i must make into a virgin tias
eliot phrased the same thought as a
mission to purify the dialect of the
tribe
she can play the cello like an angel or
he draws beautifully are proud parental
boasts but he can really talk that
especially one sense is here in england
and dare i suggest perhaps even more in
yorkshire is more insults than nincomium
inarticulacy is a sign of honesty
hesitance in utterancy
bespeaks depth of feeling
whereas fluency
eloquence and exquisite expression are
creepy untrustworthy show-offy or the
worst the worst imputation of the age
elitist
being good at language is precisely the
sort of
unhealthy attribute that suggests those
very carnal perversions of which
victorians had suspected oscar wilde of
all along
in our culture wars the lumpen
inarticulacy of someone like trump may
amuse the sneering snide snarky snobs of
the metropolitan elites but it plays
perfectly to his core our own boris
deliberately sabotages the fruity
oratunity of his words with blustering
trips pauses puffing stammers and
yammers and is loved by it by some but
not
i might venture to suggest by all
school and popular culture teach you
that no one likes a smart arts no one
likes a show-off no one likes to hear
those five dollar words those
sesquipedalian prelixities baloo the
bear speaks as he finds sheer khan the
tiger oozes and ripples with perfect
polished phrases you hug the bear and
run from the tiger
and language is so freighted and laden
music and the other arts are certainly
not stripped of connotations and
demographic markers of class education
upbringing gender outlook sexuality race
and identity but compared to language
they're all but innocent of such sinking
cargo it is impossible for an englishman
to open his mouth without making some
other englishman hate or despise him
bernard shaw famously declared in his
preface to pygmalion
selecting a minor over e flat major or
choosing say viridian over forest green
does not reveal anything about the
singers or painters backgrounds but the
keys and colors in which one speaks the
frames of reference the word choices the
pronunciations stress timings syntax
tones cadences and rhythms reveal all
and that is even before one approaches
the question of accent brogan dialect
english is the tongue i know best and it
does have some characteristics that i
can't quite claim to be unique but that
are certainly special
i can demonstrate these best through
analogy
think of london
some of its outline was determined by
romans who conquered it two thousand
years ago
since then atop the ruins of the roman
and saxon dark age and norman london
there was constructed a medieval city of
winding streets jostling half-timbered
mansions soaring stone cathedrals and
churches then came tudor and jacobean
palaces halls and playhouses and after
fire and plague a period of renewed
classical elements the squares and
avenues of georgian and regency london
elegant spacious harmonious
the victorians introduced long suburban
streets terraces warehouses libraries
mills schools town halls railway
stations and in the 20th century there
arrived a new architecture of glass and
concrete office towers corporate
headquarters airports car parks shopping
centers american and european statements
of self-conscious modernity statehood
brutalism deconstructivism sociological
planning and all these elements
all these styles fashions and fancies
now jostled together coexisting in an
arbitrary unplanned jumble of manners
materials modes and methods halved
timbered elizabethan abutting an
edwardian post office to one side and a
plate glass apple store to the other
thus a living city in which all the
expressions of its history are contained
in one
paris gorgeous paris is somewhat more
pristine it has a medieval area there's
ile de la cite it has housman's highly
designed 19th century center
everything modern is either a
self-conscious and approved grand
project or cast into the outer bowler
beyond the periphery and of course paris
avoided being blitzed which also helped
it
stop becoming as higgledy-piggledy as
london you see the analogy
as far as their language is concerned
the academy francaise has existed since
the days of cardinal riccia to ensure
that the same thing remains true of la
long francaise the demotic and vulgar
the foreign and impure are barred from
entry
the english language on the other hand
like london is a riot of unplanned
asymmetrical variegation over the
centuries artangas had conferred upon it
like london strata and scars riches and
residues from the church royalty
aristocracy theater industry commerce
international entertainment saxon and
roman elements are overlaid in our every
utterance with norman french chaucerian
church medieval english just like the
built environment not ordered or graded
according to period but as the recent
film title has it everything everywhere
all at once
a great flourishing of shakespeare the
bible of king james milton and dryden
informed the language followed by the
augustine english of johnson swift and
pope pros laid out in graceful harmony
like georgian squares while in the
alleyways thieves can't
prisoners and sailors slang enliven the
language with all kinds of new energies
the victorian english of industry
dickens and the musical mucked in too
and laterally the english of the 20th
and 21st centuries with incoming patois
creoles and dialects from india the
caribbean africa australasia and
elsewhere enriching the language all the
way through to the dominance of radio
and cinema
the discourses of fascism communism
socialism and finance the americanisms
the street talk jazz and gangster argo
the tv the rock and roll golf cricket
football the corporate speak the
computer jargon the language of hip-hop
and social media and here we are all in
one sentence modernist glass and
concrete language as it were jostling
with half-timbered elizabethan phrases
shakespeare and miltonic periods up
against psychobabble and skateboarding
slang a starbucks of an utterance
annexed to an expression that once
belonged to a victorian banker and we
pay attention to it as rarely as we look
above the plastic facial shop line and
appreciate the marvelous miscellaneous
of architecture on our high streets
just as london had no municipal planning
to houseman so english had no it can no
academy
so we are linguistic heirs not just to
milton and keats of course but to dick
turpin and the artful dodger damian
runyan johnny lydon delboy tupac shakur
coronation street and dame edna voices
and varieties too numerous and muddled
together in the english cocktail to pick
out and enumerate
of course i'm overstating somewhat
french's controlled homogeneity and i
repeat that i'm not claiming all this to
be unique to english but english is the
language i best know and for all kinds
of historical and cultural reasons not
all of them in the least admirable it's
open-hearted immigration policy
linguistically at least as
architecturally has created a richness
that may or may not be exceptional some
of you linguists here will know whether
it is but unique or not it is surely a
miracle that deserves to be acknowledged
of course the french academy's attempts
to keep franglais and other interlopers
out of the pristine boulevards of their
language can be mocked as to put it
crudely pissing into the wind but their
futile guardianship is nothing
compared to the more damaging and
preposterous guardianship of
well if you'll forgive me the easiest
way to make this point is to show you
another little clip i i put out a
podcast on language about 14 years ago
in which i ranted about linguistic
guardianship and a very clever fellow
called matthew rogers turned part of it
into a kinetic typography film which
i'll um show you now
so you
you've probably heard that um
probably heard that self-contradictory
and frankly hypocritical confession of
mine fading out at the end
h does distress me hr for human
resources you hear all the time now
pretty much nails on the blackboard to
me and i don't know why unless started
by someone irish where that usage is old
and universally attested
um full disclosure i'm not especially
thrilled by the use of yourself and
myself when all that is meant is you or
me but i dare say myself's accented
elect and manner his nails on the
blackboard to yourself too uh in
itself's own way myself also winces
people who say between you and i and i
sometimes have to bite my tongue when i
hear beg the question used to mean
invite or raise the question um but i
should and must beat down these silly
picky persnickety objections there's no
right or wrong in language any more than
there's right or wrong in nature
evolution is all about restless and
continuous and continual change mutation
variation in the animal kingdom what was
once meant to be a nose can end up as an
antenna a tongue eyes a pair of lips or
a blank space once evolution and
permutations of dna under varying
conditions have got to work if the
foulness of that kennel club mentality
was operated in nature well giraffe's
necks wouldn't be allowed to stretch and
camels wouldn't get humps such
alterations would be wrong
well it's the same in language there is
as i say again again again and again no
right no wrong only usage convention
exists of course it does but convention
is no more a register of rightness or
wrongness than etiquette is it's just
another way of saying usage things that
are kept to purity of line in the kennel
club manor develop all the ghastly
illnesses and deformations of inbreeding
and lack of vital variation imagine if
we all spoke the same language as
dickens fabulous as it is imagine if the
structure meaning and usage of language
was always the same as when swift pope
and dryden were alive superficially
appealing as an idea for about five
seconds but absurd and deluded the more
you reflect upon it
language
is ours
whoever we are whatever our reading
education employment or background it
doesn't belong to me doesn't belong to
google parliament wikipedia the bbc the
times guardian mail or facebook it
doesn't belong to the department of
education spotify apple or amazon it
doesn't even belong to the departments
of linguistics and language in
universities and colleges it belongs to
everyone with a tongue
ears keyboard pen or hands to sign
rather than reserving it only for the
banalities of life pass the mustard
where's the toilet i'm hungry shut up
what's on tv
exercise your
right to have fun with it
all right for a job interview you might
as i said adopt a more formal mode of
utterance just as you might put on
another custom suit or tie we can all do
that dress up for work and then dive
into jeans and hoodie when we get home
we can change our language as easily as
we change our clothes and we do it
without even knowing it
we have one way of talking to granny
another way of talking down the pub
where are today's sartorial dandies
however we don't you know in dress there
are very few dandies now we certainly
can't count the self-conscious
commodified met gala branding of
influencers and celebs
and where more importantly i think are
the verbal
dandies
well the kendrick lamars lem sysais m
m's that generation of poets and
songwriters they seem to get it
but what we do have here is a failure to
communicate with the assurance of
ownership with the confidence as people
like to say now of agency
let all believe that language is their
birthright let there be freedom and let
there be pleasure let there be textual
delight let there be silken words and
flinty words and sodden speeches and
soaking speeches and crackling utterance
and utterance that quivers and wobbles
like rennet let there be rapid
firecracker phrases and language that
oozes like a lake of lava words are your
birthright unlike music painting dance
and raffia work you don't have to be
taught any part of language or buy any
equipment to use it all the power of it
was in you from the moment the head of
daddy's little wiggler fused with the
wall of mummy's little bubble
so if you've got it
use it don't be afraid of it
don't believe it belongs to anyone else
don't let anyone bully you into
believing that there are rules and
secrets of grammar and verbal deployment
to which you are not privy don't listen
to dinosaurs like me moaning about h's
don't be humiliated by creeps into
thinking yourself inferior because you
can't spell broccoli or moccasins
just let the words fly from your lips
and your pen make up silly nicknames for
those you love and those you despise
devise nonsense words and mad mantras
don't sing in the shower try out accents
and gobbledygook there give your words
rhythm and depth and height and
silliness give them filth and form and
noble stupidity words are free and all
words light and frothy dour and dappled
firm and sculpted as they may be bear
the history of their passage from lip to
lip over thousands of years
how they feel to us now tells stories of
our ancestors and with every breath
builds new stories for our descendants
be a thaumaturge
set the words free
fly my pretties fly
that's enough now shut up stephen thank
you
you